the problem is a lot of people have
struggled with failing in front of
everyone when you're not built for it
and then all of a sudden you go for it
and then it fails that's failure in
front of everyone and the one reason
that most people don't do
entrepreneurship is they do fear failure
attention is the number one
asset tell me your story how you moved
here you immigrated here in
1978 yes I convinced my parents when I
was 3 years old to immigrate from the
USSR I love your by way his hat is chees
yeah Mom and Dad are in the building
um yeah I mean honestly it's a very
classic story there's lots and lots and
lots and lots of people on Earth that
have that incredible fortunate scenario
to come to this remarkable country from
another place you know for me which I
think is a little more rare I had really
exceptional parents and so it was like
this perfect storm of right place right
time right circumstance when I analyze
my life and when I look at many others
and really for the many in here which I
appreciate the comments but I know a lot
of people here don't know who I am or
don't know the depths of my story you
know really at the end of the day I'm
incredibly interested in people you know
you know one thing that just become more
and more obvious to me is I like people
more than most people like genuinely
like even even wanting to go out in the
cocktail hour and talk to people instead
of just being in my green room that's
just who I am that's who I was born from
day one to be and I was able to really
hone it over time I think practice
matters you know I I always every time I
say practice I hear Alan Iverson
practice and I understand what he was
saying but for me it's the reverse you
know a lot of people ask me about my
entrepreneurial career I I'm 47 years
old and I've been practicing for over 40
years you know like for for me it was
the only thing I did I was a you know
I'm not sure if I'm allowed to say this
in this setting but I was an atrocious
student um and and it was because I was
po committed long before people said go
all in or be passionate there was a
level of self-awareness there was a
level of self-belief there was a level
of not willing to compromise there was
something that was inside of me that
understood who I was I just really
understood it I wasn't going to
apologize for it I was definitely not in
interested in doing anything bad I was
just looking to be fully myself and you
know I I think a lot of luck with DNA a
lot of luck with circumstance and I
think it was a perfect storm even the
era that I'm growing up in what is very
clear to me is that I have a very strong
knack for understanding attention right
I just have always understood it even
when I was doing lemonade stands when I
was six seven years old back to
practicing for 40 years I was more
interested in the signs and where I was
going to put the signs to get people to
buy the lemonade than the lemonade than
even the money I was more interested in
the attention than the money so you know
look I'm 47 years old the explosion of
the internet happened just as I was
ready to go into the real world that's
just a little bit of a luck of the draw
sure I can decide that I would have been
a good newspaper man or radio man or a
TV man if I was born two generations
earlier but in all those scenarios there
are
Gatekeepers they're Gatekeepers the
internet and social media and the reason
this is such a big deal and whether you
think it's awesome or you think it's bad
there's so much that goes along with it
what everyone's struggling with is
nobody's in
control Facebook Instagram Tik Tok
YouTube these platforms are empty
there's no editor and chief there's no
head of the studio this is not a
subjective opinion it's Merit who's the
human could put in the work put in the
message that most attracts people's
attention and we judge we judge in this
room in the world who people pay
attention to but that's silly you know
that's you judging clear data that
supports that other people find XYZ
interesting we all have different
interests we all think different things
are interesting so you know I think the
story of me
is I'm very fortunate and that's why I'm
incredibly you know driven by gratitude
you know I'm I'm a very simple dude
who's doing a lot right I think when
people look at me from the outside I
have 700 trillion businesses I'm putting
out content 58 times a day I'm always up
to something but in reality I think I'm
incredibly simple which is I keep life
very basic I I'm not doing it for the
accolades or the trophies you know I'm
I'm humbled by it I'm humbled to take a
selfie but it's not what I strive for I
don't need need that my parents took
care of my self-esteem so I'm good I'm
just living my life and at this point
I'm just trying to you know there's even
a part of there's probably a level of
guilt that is a currency inside of me
that it worked so well for me that that
mix between gratitude and guilt inspires
me very heavily to try to give an ounce
to the world what's inside of me and so
that's how I roll trying to get a sense
of a little Gary Right little Gary 8 n
10 years old you know you were you had
an entrepreneurial Spirit from the from
a very young age you start eliminates
then but what and then going into high
school what stereotype bucket did you
fit in well maybe not were you the jock
were you the nerd were you The Brainiac
were you the Romeo were you the I don't
know tell me
pain that picture for us a little more I
I think you know this now makes sense to
me when I'm older I think I have unusual
outcome because I think it was a little
bit interesting like you know right
around fourth or fifth grade from The
Jock standpoint was when I transitioned
from wanting to be on the New York Jets
to thinking about buying them so up that
that was about 10 11 about 12 because
you know 789 I have such remarkable hand
eye coordination that I was able to
dominate first and second grade but
somewhere around fourth and fifth grade
this things changed a little bit you had
to actually be strong and fast and
athletic and all these other things I'm
like uhoh this might be a problem um I
was I was really a bad student like you
know by fourth grade I know Mom I had to
actually ask my high school to send me
the report card because my mom changed
the story and her mom and this in her
mind and decided I was a c student but
by fourth and fifth grade I started
getting a lot of and Fs and and that was
actually extremely challenging you know
I had a lot of teachers and a lot of my
friends parents really communicate to me
in an incredibly negative way because of
my grades right like I remember you know
for the people over 45 you might
remember this for the kids this might be
a a reference that doesn't land but for
some reason in the late 80s early 9s the
way they tried to scare you and I feel
terrible for people in in the sanitation
business but the amount of teachers that
told me I was going to end up being a
garbage man was like staggering it was
like an everyday
barrage um but for me this is why I love
entrepreneurship there
were the you know Sports started to tell
me I wasn't good enough right and that's
was a very early first second grade
dream my my teachers were definitely
telling me that I wasn't good enough
that started bleeding into my friend's
parents having comments and snarky
comments but the two places that always
told me I was good enough was
home and Business right you know like
when I started selling baseball cards in
sixth grade I was the best at it you
know I was the best at business so the
open the reason I love the market and
the world is the world's always been
good to me it's always told me that I
was good right and so I think a lot
about positive affirmation I think a lot
about the parents in this room that have
kids and I think a lot about what what
do they tell their kids meaning what are
they cheering for right for me that's a
very interesting game I struggle with
cheering for things that are very
transactional you know I fear that I
fear that it makes our kids robotic and
it makes them every 90 days and it makes
them robots and I think we strugg a
society to understand creativity to
understand different and I got I got
very fortunate I think and and I'll tell
you another thing what I what I really
think my mom drilled which is a super
challenge because I'll be honest with
you I'm not great at it as a parent was
she she made me not think my grades were
a reflection of who I was going to
become but she held me accountable for
having bad grades to find the balance of
making me believe that these bad grades
would not Define me but also grounding
me every 3 months when my report card
came home is a very fine tight rope that
I think every parent here can understand
is almost impossible like I I really
struggle to see it cuz I think we go too
far in any direction and
so you know to answer you directly
little Gary by fourth grade understood
he was going to win the World nobody was
going to stop him and he lived in his
own cocoon I lived in my own head and so
your parents were entrepreneurial they
were small business owners at what age
would you say you really understood the
word
entrepreneurship I mean entrepreneurship
wasn't a word like when did I realize
entrepreneurship I don't know
2006 like the word was businessman there
was no entrepreneurship as a matter of
fact and this will land with people over
40 the only times I heard the word
entrepreneur by the time I was 35 was
I'd heard it randomly and it usually
meant the person was a loser right it
meant that they were like making pretend
to be a business like I remember
businessman was here an entrepreneur was
here and usually thought it was like
someone using mommy and daddy's money to
make protect it's actually now become
that
again but when I was growing up I mean
you rarely I mean I actually think
Entrepreneur magazine might have been
the first time I even like going on a
wine trip I grew up in my dad's business
in the wine business I actually remember
maybe going to Napa in my early 20s and
seeing Entrepreneur magazine on the
shelf and I was like it was just I just
thought I was a businessman and
so and it you have to understand again
there's no entrepreneur when all the
kids we just talked to when I was their
age there was no businessman that you
put on a pedestal it's now popular
culture it's now cool there was nothing
cool about businessmen what I like the
most like entrepreneurial or most
successful businessman when I was like
in high school was the [__] biggest
nerd on
Earth there was nothing you were
aspiring to it was like you you thought
you know like it was just not this way
today it's a it's you know and I think
about this a lot I think people don't
you know the one class I was solid at
and not got Epson was history and I
think about I use history a lot as a
frame of reference for the future so you
know 70 years ago 60 years ago a pilot
and an astronaut was super famous in
America like astronauts off the charts
and Pilots were like whoa like athletes
in the
1950s professional athletes took summer
jobs or offseason jobs because they
didn't get paid enough literally Yankees
that won World Series would then go work
in hardware stores in Hoboken cuz they
were getting paid so little or Less in
comparison and now they get paid you
know $70 million a year and so I think
you know I think things change and I
think the entrepreneur really hit fever
pitch 3 four five years ago and I think
about that a lot because I'm worried
about that to be honest how so well I
think if you TR if you think
entrepreneurship is cool like being a
rapper or a rockar or like the cool
stuff well then you try to become one
which is amazing the the problem is
entrepreneurship is not like School
entrepreneurship is not like your
parents entrepreneurship doesn't care
about your
feelings entrepreneurship is not
fake entrepreneurship is not something
you can easily like figure out and the
results you can't hide when you get a
bad grade you can like blame the
teacher right you can do stuff when you
work in government like it's a machine
in Corporate America machine you can
hide there's a reason saying like
succcess has a million fathers failure
has none exist there are many many many
many fake environments in the world but
Sports you can't fake last night the
Jets played they lost they almost won it
they almost won all right they did all
right for another game that happened to
happen yesterday was the Dolphins got
their face beat
in sports you know can't the Dolphins
can't wake up today and be like oh we
did it but you can do that corporate you
can do that it's fake in a lot of places
on Earth Sports is not fake the closest
thing to sports is
entrepreneurship your business either
works or it doesn't you either make
money or you don't it either stays alive
or goes out of business and what I worry
about is a lot of people who are not
actual entrepreneurs who are you know
playing entrepreneur or not purebred I
want everyone to be an entrepreneur if
they are one but for a lot of people
they're a number two they're number four
they're number eight and that's amazing
you you know some people are stay-home
dad some people are a lawyer like
there's we need everything and that's
amazing I don't want people to be
entrepreneurs I want people to be
self-aware to figure out what makes them
happy and live that life when we made
entrepreneurship so cool a lot of people
went for it the problem is a lot of
people have struggled with failing in
front of everyone you know when when
you're not built for it and then all of
a sudden you go for it and then it
fails that's failure in front of
everyone one and the one reason that
most people don't do entrepreneurship is
they do fear
failure and I think a lot about fear and
failure I think one of the great things
that happened to me was I did love
sports which meant I lost a lot and then
with school I was losing so much in
fourth fifth 6th seventh grade that by
the time I was 14 I was used to losing I
would argue I loved losing I think it's
why I love being a Jets fan
I'm being serious I'm being serious as
pissed as I was last night there is a
secret percentage of me that was like
good good you know like like you know
and I think I think that is a
characteristic of an entrepreneur and
that was a huge characteristic of mine I
think a lot about the kids that I see
now that run away from playing something
cuz they're scared to lose for me I was
the reverse I would play and play and I
would cry I cried a lot when I was a kid
if you want to know about me I cried
tried a lot at 99 10 11 12 but I would
just get up again and play and get up
again and play and I think we've done a
terrible job in our society on
demonizing losing when we give kids
eighth place
trophies we we confuse them you
understand we start to tell them as
parents losing is bad so we have cuz
they know I promise all the parents in
here when your kids eight and they get
an eighth place trophy they know it's
weird and when we give them that trophy
we're telling them losing is so bad we
need to like coddle your feelings and
we're going to give you this [__]
Trophy and what ends up happening is it
doesn't set them up for real life
because real life happens and it doesn't
work that way before we go to NE I want
to ask you one question about failing
what's your biggest professional
fail I could take the next I passed on U
you heard that I invested in Uber in the
second
round I passed on Uber twice and I wrote
my first book I wrote was called crush
it I acknowledged only my family and one
random person the founder of uber Travis
cuz he helped when I wrote the book he
was the person I sent it to and he gave
me great feedback and I wanted to
acknowledge Him we were real friends
friends and I keep a very small circle I
have a lot of acquaintances but friends
small he pitched it to me twice the
first time I passed the second time he
ped I mean I it was in this like Grove
in San Francisco I think I stopped going
to San Francisco because I didn't want
to drive by it he pitched me
emphatically like hey I really want you
in and it's funny it goes back to
offense versus defense I just bought my
first meaningful apartment in Manhattan
and I was a little less cashr than I was
accustomed to and I just didn't feel
like I wanted to write that 25 or
$50,000 check which I could have that
$25 to $50,000 check check I left 400
million on the
table all right that is a
fail however it's not a fail fail fail
well I don't know how to fail fail fail
cuz my parents taught me how to save
money okay I don't bet the farm to go to
zero I you know my failures are things
I've left on the table my failures are
the things I didn't do that I when
Steven Ross the owner of the Miami
Dolphins bought a piece of Vayner media
he offered us and me and my brother
instead of cash he offered a piece of
the Miami Dolphins I out of pure emotion
because it was a good business deal
because I hate the dolphins with my
entire
heart passed on
that instead of the the $25 million in
cash that we got to put into a fund and
a couple maybe 10 more million in cash
for me and AJ to split to take home that
35 is
probably 350
million so I don't know I've told you
two stories that I've already left $700
million on the table I mean I can I can
go
on I mean this is the life of an
entrepreneur like honestly I know what
those numbers I mean honestly I'm saying
it out loud I'm like what the [__] but
like you know like I understand what it
sounds like but the reality is is like
I'm not doing it for the
money I think that's the biggest reason
we have so many fake entrepreneurs I
think the majority of them are doing it
for the money I think most people go
into entrepreneurship or business to buy
things that the business allowed them to
buy I just want to build businesses I
just want to play my game and so I've
made a ton of mistakes but the one that
I most regret is the one I've been most
working on I really struggled with
cander in my professional career which
is wild because as a public figure and
as a personality when I'm talking to the
world cander is my strength but when I
spoke to people individually that worked
for me or that I cared about I struggled
with it CU if I like you telling you the
truth that you're not doing well at
something was a real struggle for me and
by the way authentically still is but
I've worked on it a lot the last four or
five years and I think it's really
impacted my business in a very positive
way the thing I most regret are the
people that I fired along the way who
really weren't good at their jobs but I
never set them up to f fix it because I
couldn't tell them the truth and then I
would surprise them and just fire them
and it's a huge regret and by far the
biggest mistake of my career and I'm
proud that I'm working on it
that's so we're going to Pivot a little
bit and talk about parenting and I I've
seen a lot of your content on Instagram
and I've never heard uh we have some
questions that probably never heard so
having you spoke about micro adversities
now of those micro adversity really
contributed to your success now you talk
a little bit about some of the struggles
that you had I'm sure all that fil your
emotional forance you to handle fil
there are a lot of immigrants here in
this room and there are a lot of people
who came to this country who have made a
big and Mal Bible talks about this too
they're not able to recreate those same
conditions like you're not going to have
your daughter in a studio with eight
people having to re what you can't fake
environment so I think the big question
that a lot of people here are interested
in is how do you build that same
strength how do you build that same uial
Drive what hope is there
none look it's hard to be hungry when
you're
fed you know and so in a room of a lot
of immigrants who made it like is anyone
confused like you're living it you know
there's a reason it works the way it
does and I also challenge all of us
parents who've lived that Journey that
we shouldn't idolize how we did it and
that shouldn't be imposed on our
children we should maybe
idolize you know things that we like
about our kindness who we are as human
beings but we're not going to be able to
replicate the environment I mean I sit
on the board of pencils of promise and
charity water we do a ton of work in
Africa to build schools where there are
no schools to get clean water there's
seven by the way you want to be grateful
real fast there are 750 million people
on earth almost 10% that do not have
access to clean water we worry about
dumb silly things like our internet's
slow right or like silly things and
there's 10% of our society doesn't have
access to clean water think about that
so I sit on these boards I have all my
wealthy friends many who came up the way
I did with less than more and they're
like Gary can you take my 15-year-old
son to Africa for a week I want to
really show them I'm like okay but like
just to save you some time they're not
going to come back and be totally
different people like you know we try to
do all these silly tactics we're not
going to win that game I think what we
can do I think we need to focus on
Civility and humanity and and like good
traits one thing we do very poorly is we
create ideology that can't be
accomplished it is the human Spirit we
need to get off the religious bandwagon
of that you can recreate it you can't
right you can control it you can you can
mitigate it money is a big one you know
I have you know I talked to my parents
about my situation and I'm always like
well there's going to be an age where I
stop giving it to them and like I look
at their eyes and I walk away and I know
they're laughing at me because they
think it's already too late at 14 and I
think oh no that's the right time and
you know you go by stories have
unlimited friends who came up in in very
wealthy environments whose parents made
them get jobs and stopped giving them
money around 14 15 16 and when I analyze
them versus friends who didn't in over
40 50 people it feels a little bit
better but we're not going to be able
like you know my kids are not going to
work in my dad's liquor store for 15
hours a day from 15 years old on 7 days
a week for 20 years that's not happening
right and that's okay it allows me to
make fun of them that they're so
soft so I think you highlighted in some
of this but talk to us a little bit
about the this hustle mindset like this
working hard grinding through the night
but yet maintaining integrity and really
emphasizing character well that's that's
where we screw up words and like it's
funny even that you ask that I'll
explain what I mean by that the reason
you ask that is we manipulate
words you know when I was growing up
hustle meant hard work cuz Pete Rose was
Charlie hustle and he worked hard and
like that was a good word then to your
point somewhere in the last 5 to 10
years the word hustle kind of got
conformed into and I know that the word
hustle is like I hustled him so there
was a negative connotation but to me
when you just asked that question I
laugh like why would work ethic
compromise honor those are the two
easiest things to balance on Earth so I
you know I think I think that just comes
down to how we interpret words I used
hustle as a public figure from 2006 to
2014 aggressively it communicated what I
believed which is there's a lot of
things all of us cannot control but one
thing we can all control is how much
effort we put into
things it's the most controllable
thing um but then the word got
manipulated and started to mean burnout
or win at all costs or money over
everything and so I walked away from
that word I mean my usage of that word
is so low now I just use work ethic it
allows me to explain the same thing I'm
not emotionally attached to any words
but being able to balance work ethic
with doing the right thing is the only
thing I believe
in very nice so so I'll give you one to
build on if I may yeah I I think one I'm
sorry to jump in but this really that
really inspired me there's another thing
I think a lot about so how many here how
many people here by show of hands
consume some of my content or have a
good gist of my content raise your hands
thank you so for the people that raised
your hands for the other people that
didn't one of my favorite things to talk
about is patience I'm obsessed with it I
believeing it the most I think it leads
to very good behavior I think impatience
leads is often an indication of
insecurity rushing for success to show
others not themselves and so for me I
push patience a lot I'm stunned by how
many people struggle with me pushing
patience because they hear
complacency cuz you know and and I'm
fascinated by people's inability to
balance words that may seem in
contradiction to me I'm as ambitious as
they come I'm hungry I'm sitting here
today and there's not a person in the
audience that scares me that they're
hungrier because I don't feel fulfilled
I'm still super driven I feel like I
haven't even started and so I sit here
hungry but I equally impatient you know
when when you know when I hear about my
life Lo and gold to buy the New York
Jets right like a lot of people now that
I'm in public figure like when are you
going to do it next year next and it's
funny I see all these people out in the
open at the happen today at the airport
at in nework guys's like when are you
going to buy the Jets and I'm like 32
years
and like the disappointment in his
face and and so I I think people
struggle to balance what may seem like
contradictions and I think in that
there's something important to dig
into yeah I think you reframe the word I
actually your explanation helps helps
reframe a lot so last question before we
open up keep a hand um ai ai that's been
a huge topic of conversation across
industry especially
yes I'd love to hear a little bit about
how is that influenced contact creation
and and how are you grappling with kind
of the way the market has evolv as
result I mean it's I mean do you know
the history of how we talked about
electricity as a society when it first
hit so I don't know if you know this
most people demonized electricity when
it was invented most conventional like
conversations were that it was demons in
our
house it was so new and so profound
that the concept of electricity versus
candles was too much and we decided that
it's bad I couldn't believe more that
that's what we're doing with AI right
now that people are focusing on
demonizing it because let me make this
very clear to this Auditorium AI is
bananas big it is one of the most
significant technology advancements in
humankind it will change absolutely
everything it is a big deal it's the
invention of the internet big it is
going to absolutely change Industries
company's Fortune it will reset the deck
and
whomever governments whomever private
companies whomever entrepreneurs and
personality harnesses AI for their
advantage will win and so right now for
example and you know as a bad student I
have some of my own personal pent up
feelings to the education system
education I believe in more than
anything in the world it's how the world
advances how it's packaged and sold is
always a feeling I have in my tummy when
the AI thing started happening 18 months
ago 12 months ago of course school
started to ban it right and I was
laughing as if these kids are not going
to live in a world of AI like as if we
like even just the whole concept like
making kids memorize stuff when all the
information's on the phone right
not allowing them to use AI cuz what we
have a religious belief that they should
write the paper I think it's epic that
they write the paper in one second let
them go do whatever else they want to
do the kids like that
one the kids like that one look look I I
I think that we tend to demonize the
most important things and we've done
this before we like we've like we don't
understand it's how people use it and
it's on us not the thing we've tried
Banning things in society remember
prohibition that didn't work out you
know like like humans are going to be
humans they're going to do their thing I
I've got a news alert AI is not going
back into the Genie bottle we're not
going backwards right and there's a lot
of people in this room who have a
negative point of view on AI who also
said they were never going to get an
iPhone because their Blackberry had
buttons on
it a lot
yeah and I also remember them saying
they're never going to get a Blackberry
because their pager was good enough and
they didn't want to have a phone so that
people could bother them any time if
they wanted them they could page them
and you would call them when you were
ready B people demonized the internet
people demonized email people demon
people really cuz I was at the Forefront
of it people super demonized social
media everybody told me they'd never be
on Facebook cuz that was for kids and so
we're very good at saying
no and I think I've built my entire
happiness and professional success on
maybe and so I highly recommend if you
remember anything I said tonight way too
many parents when they parent kids way
too many professionals when they think
about their futures or make decisions of
new technologies you default into no
which means actually you've lost on
impact if you were a no person it's
already over you lost
no is not protecting you the way you
think no is the only losing formula
maybe with an open mind to the side yes
or no is what a lot of you are doing
with no maybe is what you're searching
for maybe is what leads to happiness a
better relationship with your child a
better opportunity in business it's
maybe that we need to fall in love with
this no culture we live in is a huge
huge limiter of joy and profits
yes